it's great to welcome back to the
program Johann Hari who is the author of
the book lost connections uncovering the
real causes of depression and the
unexpected solutions Johan it's great to
have you back on last time we were
talking about the war on drugs and
there's sort of a collect connection
between the treatment of depression and
drugs and this is a particularly
interesting topic to me I have a lot of
people in my family who have worked in
the mental health field for a very very
long time many of them with very diverse
views on issues such as the treatment of
depression so let's just to set this the
sort of stage for the conversation how
did this become something you started
researching it was very personal for me
there were these two mysteries that were
really hanging over me and to be honest
I was really frightened to look into
them it's a sign of how frightened I was
to investigate this that I wanted to
start doing this seven years ago and I
decided it would be easier to go and
spend time with hit men for the Mexican
drug cartels to my other book instead
and the first mystery was why was I
still depressed I've gone to my doctor
when I was a teenager and I'd explained
to him you know I had this feeling like
pain was leaking out of me like a kind
of bad smell I couldn't regulate it I
couldn't understand why it was happening
and it was very frightening and my
doctor told me his story he said we know
why you feel this way there's a chemical
called serotonin in people's brains
you're clearly lacking it gonna give you
these drugs to boost your levels of
serotonin you're gonna feel fine and I
thought a tremendous boost even before I
took the drugs I felt a tremendous boost
to be given a story about why I felt
this way and I started taking them and I
thought a really significant boost for a
few months and then that sense of pain
started to bleed back through so I went
back he gave me a high dose I felt bit
better again and a little bit faster
this time the pain came back and I was
in that kind of cycle and so for 13
years I was taking I was drugging myself
in this way and at the end of it I
thought why I'm why do I still feel this
way I'm doing everything I'm told to do
the second mystery which was a much more
important one is they wanted to
understand why so many people in our
culture were starting to feel really
depressed and anxious
one in five Americans takes a
psychiatric drug and one in 11 people
takes an antidepressant I was like
what's going on here and instinctively I
thought
it can't be just that there's something
chemically going wrong in everyone's
brain spontaneously and that seems to be
happening more there must be more to
this story than that I think when you
have a story about your pain in your
distress even if it doesn't work very
well it's like putting a kind of leash
on that pain you know it's like putting
a leash on a wild animal at least you
know where it is and and so I went on
this big long journey I went over 40,000
miles I met with the best scientists in
the world who studied what causes
depression and anxiety and how to solve
them
and I went to places that just have very
different perspectives from an Amish
community in Indiana because the Amish
have very low levels of depression to a
city in Brazil where they ban
advertising to see if it would make
people feel better to a lab at one of
the best universities in the United
States where they were giving people
psilocybin the active component in magic
mushrooms to see if that made them feel
better and and I learned many things the
first thing I learned is that the story
I was taught by my doctor is not true
and professor Andrew Scholl at Princeton
University says it is deeply misleading
an unscientific to say that depression
is just very low sentiment
dr. David Healy one of the experts and
Britain said to me you can't even say
that story has been discredited because
it was never actually accredited there's
never a time when half of the scientists
and the field believed it was been
essentially promoted by the drug company
PRS but the fact that it's not cause
we're certain doesn't mean there's no
value in chemical antidepressants this
song value and for most people is
relatively small I thought I was a freak
all that time actually I was completely
normal
depression is measured by something
called the Hamilton scale I've always
felt sorry for whoever Hamilton was that
he's remembered for just how miserable
people there if you're at one on the
Hamilton scale you would be dancing
around in ecstasy and if you're at 51
you would be acutely suicidal and to
give you a sense of what movement on the
Hamilton scale looks like improving your
sleep patterns will give you a six point
improvement on the Hamilton scale so
lemon cars there if we can Johan just
because there's already a lot there that
I want to talk about just to see where
we can where we agree and where we sort
of disagree so I agree that the sort of
simplifying of the depression is a
chemical chemical imbalance to
not enough serotonin has to even you're
right and to say it's even been debunked
might not be true because it was never
even really a confirmed or postulated
theory to begin with but I do think that
the term chemical imbalance is a little
more complex in the sense that chemical
imbalance can mean not that the level of
serotonin isn't right
but that it's a brain that's failing to
correctly or well enough regulate
emotion for example it's not so much an
imbalance in a particular chemical but
it's still brain related do we sort of
agree on at least that part so I have
all chapter in lost connections about
the changes that do happen in the brain
when someone becomes depressed that do
make it harder to get out of depression
those brain changes are not the cause
but they make it harder for you to get
out and they go through particularly the
work of professor Mark Lewis he's really
explained I think most clearly and
brilliantly the nature of those changes
now he says those changes should not be
described as a chemical imbalance I mean
I think the point you're making is
essentially right and get into a kind of
semantic disagreement about the words
you use to describe it but no you're
right there are real biological factors
that contribute to depression and
anxiety and there are people who deny
that and they're completely wrong so we
grant then I guess to take it a step
further if we grant that there certainly
are some biological factors maybe what
the model that we build is one where
those biological factors might serve as
a sort of predisposition where in
stressful situations or in particular
circumstances or when experiencing
certain emotions one is predisposed to
suffer from depression and/or anxiety
based on their biological makeup is that
do we still can sort of continue to
agree more sensitive to so it's worth
looking at in a little bit more detail
so we know how much one person's bones
has set and sensitivity to depression
anxiety is due to due to your genes it's
quite a broad scientific consensus on
this it's between 30 and 40 percent the
way we know it is actually you think
they've been more sophisticated way of
doing this but there isn't you compare
tentacle twins and non-identical twins
because obviously identical twins are
more genetically similar than non
identical twins when you compare those
rates you can figure out how much
something is genetic that's how we know
that 90% of your height is genetic is
genetically determined not 100% so under
slavery for example as african-americans
what an average shorter than white
Americans now they're on average taller
because of all the horrific and barbaric
poor nutrition and all that horrific and
barbaric things that were done to them
so genes are not destiny even with
something like high with with depression
anxiety 35 so 30 to 40 percents about
35% of your susceptibility your
sensitivity is due to that but there's a
very important kind of caveat to that
professor Absalom caspin did the most
detailed research on the genetics of
depression he looks at this big New
Zealand population study it's really
fascinating study and it found a
particular gene that does increase your
vulnerability to depression and anxiety
it's called the h5 t t gene
I also found so really interesting if
you carry that gene you are more like
you're more vulnerable to depression
anxiety but only if you experience a
trauma or if you become acutely lonely
if you carry that gene but you don't
experience an extreme tool man you don't
become acutely lonely you're no more
likely to become depressed and anxious
and someone who doesn't carry that gene
I think that tells something about the
biological factors so there are three
kinds of cause of depression and anxiety
that play out and everyone who becomes
depressed some degree there's biological
factors which are real the psychological
factors how you think about yourself in
life and then there's social factors
which have the environment how we live
together and they all play a role but
the biological factors seem to increase
your vulnerability to the social and
psychological factors they don't
determine them so anyone who's been told
ins it's told to a lot of people that
you were born with depression you
inherited your depression and I thought
that for a while my mother had been very
depressed when I was before I was born
and when I was born that is not true it
can make you more vulnerable but it
doesn't write your destiny let's pause
there we're speaking with Johann Hari
who's author author of the new book lost
connections uncovering the real causes
of depression and the unexpected
solutions and that's exactly where we
will pick up our conversation with him
in part two of the interview
we're continuing our conversation with
Johan Hari he is author of the book lost
connections uncovering the real causes
of depression and the unexpected
solutions so in part one we really sort
of focused on understanding building a
model of the causes of depression which
as we talked about have a biological
component they have a social component
they have sort of situational component
what I'd like to transition into is what
works and what doesn't work
and in that context certainly we would
talk about pharmaceuticals which have a
pretty wide range of success and lack of
success depending on the circumstances
and the individuals that take them so
let's maybe start on solutions a little
bit I think to understand the solutions
you've got to understand some of the
specific causes everyone listening to
this knows that they have natural
physical needs right you've got to have
food shelter water you know clean air if
I took any of those things away from you
David you'd be in trouble really fast
one of the things that connects seven of
the nine causes of depression and
anxiety that I could find scientific
evidence for is there's equally strong
evidence that we have natural
psychological needs right you've got to
feel you belong you got to throw your
life has meaning and purpose you've got
to feel that you have a future you can
understand there's a range of
psychological needs and our culture is
good at lots of things but it's been
getting less and less good at meeting
some of these deep underlying
psychological needs I'll give you a very
clear example of that and then a
solution so I notice the lots the people
I know who are depressed and anxious
their depression and anxiety focuses on
their work so start to look at what
what's the evidence for how people feel
about their work Gallup has done the
most detailed research on this they
found 13% of us like our jobs we look
forward to than most of the time 63% of
people are what they called sleepwalking
through their works you don't like it
you don't hate it 24% of people hate
their work so you think about that 87%
of people don't like the thing they're
doing most of the time I was like okay
what's what's going on here so it could
not be affecting our emotional and
mental health I discovered an amazing
Australian social scientists have done
the best research of this in the 1970s
guy called Michael Marmot who I got to
know see I can tell you how if you want
to give you the headline he discovered
the key factor not the only one but the
key factor that causes depression at
work not just not just unhappiness
depression actually even makes you more
likely to have a stress-related heart
attack if you go to work and you feel
you have no or little control
so you're just told what to do you are
significantly more likely to become
depressed and I think that's because we
all have an innate named the meaning in
our lives right and if you're controlled
all the time it disrupts your ability to
create meaning now that is a cause of
depression so I started thinking about
what would an antidepressant for that
look like so I went to Baltimore mmm I
met an amazing person called Meredith
Keough so Meredith and I think it's
really connects with a lot of things you
cover on your show so brilliantly David
Meredith used to go to bed every Sunday
like just sit with anxiety she had an
office job it wasn't the worst doctor's
job in the world she wasn't being
bullied or harassed but she just
couldn't bear the thought this was gonna
be her life that's four years and one
day with her husband Josh she did this
quite bold thing Josh had worked in bike
stores since he was a teenager and one
day you know it's insecure controlled
work as you can imagine one day with his
friends I mean the bikes Len they were
like what does that boss actually do
they quite liked their boss it was at
the bad guy but they thought well we fix
all the banks they didn't like this
experience of being boss too they
decided to do an experiment
they opened a rival bike store it's
called Baltimore bicycle works and it
doesn't work like most workplaces it's
but it's a democratic cooperative they
don't have a boss they take all the
decisions together big decisions they
share out the good tasks and the bad
tasso no one gets stuck with only the
bad tasks they obviously share the
income and what in this completely fits
professor marmots findings well this was
so fascinating to me is how many of them
talked about having been depressed and
anxious before and said they weren't
depressed and anxious in this different
environment that's important to say it's
not like they quit their jobs fixing
bikes and went off to become Beyonce's
backing singers right they fixed bikes
before they fix bikes now well they
change was the thing that causes
depression and anxiety which is being
controlled now I would argue that is an
antidepressant and as Josh put it that
innocence where I think it connects with
so much of the work you do on
corporations there is no reason why any
workplace should be structured in this a
depressogenic controlled way every
workplace could be a democratic work
very recently that the modern
corporation in its current form in human
history came into existence imagine how
many people you know who feel terrible
at the moment it would feel differently
if they knew that tomorrow they were
going into a workplace that they
controlled with their colleagues where
they could use their creativity and set
to set the priorities for the workplace
where there has to be a boss he's
elected and accountable to them that's a
completely different way of living and I
think a lot of that 87% of people in our
culture who dread or don't like the
thing they're doing most of the time
would start to feel differently about it
so in terms of so that's a very
interesting sort of situational
antidepressant as far as the more
traditional so-called treatments what do
you think is the role of antidepressants
typically the SSRI family not for
everybody but for some short term or
long term psychotherapy and of course
there's different modalities of that and
we could sort of assess the value of one
versus another in treating depression
what what's your sense of the different
sort of typical treatments that are out
there one of the things that I was
learning intellectually about these nine
causes of depression or anxiety and I
was kind of taking it on board and it
really kind of emotionally locked into
place for me when when I met this
amazing South African psychiatrist
called Derrick Sommerfeld and Derrick
happened to be in Cambodia when chemical
antidepressants were first introduced
there and the doctors there the
Cambodian doctors didn't know what it
worked what they were right so Derrick
explained and they said I wouldn't need
them we've already got antidepressants
and he said what do you mean he thought
I'm going to talk about like a herb or
remedy they told him a story there was a
farmer in their community who one day
had stood on a landmine from the
American invasion of Southeast Asia
and his leg had been blown off and they
gave him an artificial limb and he went
back to work in the rice fields but
apparently it's very painful to work
with an artificial bin in water
I imagine it was quite traumatic cousins
back in the fields we've been blown up
he starts to cry all day
classic depression and they said to
Derrick well we gave him an
antidepressant he said what did you do
they said well we were explained they
went and sat with him they listened to
his problems they realized that his pain
made sense it wasn't a pathology and
they figured well if we bought in Macau
we could become a dairy farmer and you
know then he wouldn't have to be in this
situation so they brought in an account
within a few weeks he stopped crying in
his depression when they said to Derrick
so you see doctor that care was an
antidepressant so I looked at lots of
places all over the world where they
have tried to pick up these insights and
and I found that they certainly placed a
chemical antidepressants 1.8 points on
the Hamilton scale is not zero points on
the Hamilton scale i well understand why
lots of people choose that option and
why it outweighs some of the really
significant side effects for a lot of
people therapy is great I've had a
therapist for 12 years I'm strongly in
favor of it I have a chapter about it in
the book but the most impressive
response is that I found were ones that
built on this insight about not trying
to blunt the symptoms but trying to deal
with the causes I'll give you one more
quick example as a doctor in East London
one of the heroes of my book lost
connections called Sam ever Anton so Sam
is a doctorate poor part of East London
actually where I lived for a long time
but they sadly was never my doctor and
Sam was really uncomfortable because
lots of people would come to him who
were depressed and anxious and he would
listen to their lives and he think we'll
of course you depressed I'm anxious
you're right to be depressed or anxious
you're being treated really badly you're
really lonely for example and but he'd
been taught in medical school even
though he actually knew the science was
much more sophisticated to say to people
who just got a chemical imbalance
we'll just drug you like me he's not
against the drugs he just thought this
is not enough so he tried an experiment
Sam I give you an example one of his
patients a woman called Lisa Cunningham
came to see him well I got to know Lisa
had been shut away in her home crippled
with depression and anxiety for seven
seven years and Lisa came to see Sam and
he said to our giving the drugs don't
worry I'm going to prescribe you
something else I'm gonna prescribe for
you to take part in a group there was an
area behind the doctors surgery that's
just kind of scrubland
and said we're going to support you I
want you to come a couple of times a
week and meet with other people here
other depressed and anxious people and I
want you just to turn this into
something beautiful Lisa was physically
sick with anxiety when she turned up to
that first one as time went on as the
weeks and months went by they
taught themselves gardening they have
got their fingers in the soil they had
same to talk about that wasn't how bad
they felt as human beings do when they
get together in groups they started to
solve each other's problems you know one
of the people in the group was sleeping
on the bus everyone else the public bus
everyone else was outraged they they
they started lobbying the local
authorities to get him a apartment which
succeeded they'd done something to
someone else which made them feel great
as Lisa put it to me as the flowers
began to bloom we began to believe there
was a study in Norway that found this
approach which is called social
prescribing is more than twice as
effective as chemical antidepressants I
think is it's dealing with the deep
under light one of the deep underlying
reasons why people feel so bad if you
have a human society that is you know
increasingly socially isolated when
people are cut off and told to think of
themselves just as economic maximizes
but people are constantly being told
that life is about money and status
which there's very strong proof makes
you depressed where people who make this
just think like this about screaming at
each other through Springs and then you
tell people the reason you feel about is
just cause you're biologically broken is
gonna create an environment where what
we've been doing it for 30 years and we
can see the results every year we've
done it depression and anxiety have
risen and if we carry on with this
approach it will carry on riseling that
the work this is not some wacky view
from me right is the Pacific World
Health Organization right
World Health Organization explained in
2011 mental health is produced socially
it is a social indicator above all else
it requires social solutions as well as
individual solutions the United Nations
in their official statement last year
for World Health Day said we needed to
talk less about chemical imbalances more
about power imbalances the kind of thing
that you cover every day sure yeah and
there is no question that many of the
elements of Western modern society that
have become sort of status quo and and
sort of the unquestionable elements of
it are definitely too connected to a lot
of what it is that that were identifying
we've been speaking with Johann Hari
he's author of the book lost connections
uncovering the real causes of depression
and the unexpected solutions Johan
thanks so much for talking to us about
this any more information they
to find out what Glenn Greenwald Naomi
Klein Hillary Clinton Elton John has
said about the book then go to WWE lost
connections calm they can hear audio
with loads of the scientists we've been
talking about and they can take a quiz
to see how much they know about the root
causes of depression anxiety and David
thank you for all the work you do every
day it's so important and exciting thank
you